[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing why on earth harry potter
couldn't see thestrals until seemingly
the beginning of the order of the
phoenix
a thestral is a breed of winged horse
with skeletal and reptilian features
they sort of look like an evil pegasus
the following excerpt from the order of
the phoenix
depicts harry's initial reaction to
thestrals
if he had to give them a name he
supposed he would have called them
horses though there was something
reptilian about them too
they were completely fleshless their
black coats clinging to their skeletons
of which every bone was visible their
heads were dragonish
and their pupillous eyes white and
staring
wings sprouted from each wither vast
black leathery wings that looked as
though they ought to belong to giant
bats
standing still in quiet in the gathering
gloom the creatures looked eerie and
sinister the ministry of magic considers
thestrals to be very dangerous
and they have a bad rap as omens of
misfortune
because they are only visible to those
who have seen death
the following exchange between luna and
harry confirms this
they're called thestrals they're quite
gentle really
but people avoid them because they're a
bit different
but why can't others see them they can
only be seen by people who've seen
death now before the events of the order
of the phoenix
we know that harry witnesses death on
numerous occasions
first when his parents died next when
quirrell died
and lastly and most recently in this
case when cedric diggory died
all of these deaths actually occurred
before the end of the goblet of fire
which is why it's interesting that harry
still couldn't see thestrals at that
point in time
at the end of the gobbler to fire the
carriages still appeared horseless to
harry
page 629 depicts this
hermione turned away smiling at the
horseless carriages which were now
trundling towards them up the drive as
crumb looking surprised but gratified
signed a fragment of parchment for ron
then
on page 178 of the order of the phoenix
harry sees thestrals for the first time
here stood the hundred or so horseless
stagecoaches
that always took the students above
first deer up to the castle
harry glanced quickly at them turned
away to keep it look out for ron and
hermione
then did a double take the coaches were
no longer horseless
there were creatures standing between
the carriage shafts on
page 394 of the order of the phoenix
after harry has actually witnessed
the thestrals we're reminded again in an
exchange between hagrid and students
how it is that you are actually able to
see them don't worry
it won't hurt ya said hagrid patiently
right now
you can tell me why samaya can see him
some can't
hermione raised her hand go on then
said hagrid beaming at her the only
people who can see thestrals
she said are people who have seen death
that's exactly right
said hagrid solemnly as you'll all
remember
during the events of the triwizard
tournament cedric diggory was murdered
by peter pettigrew's evada cadaver
harry witnessed this murder first hand
as this transpired a month
before the end of the spring term it's
interesting that harry
could still not see thestrals at the end
of term harry and cedric
who were tied for first place completed
the third task together
and when they both took hold of the
tri-wizard cup they were transported to
the little hangleton graveyard
where lord voldemort and peter pettigrew
awaited their arrival
this was the beginning of the end for
cedric on page 621
of the goblet of fire the book indicates
that harry was in shock following
cedric's murder
but was still able to relay the story of
cedric's death
to mr and mrs diggory when he looked
back
even a month later harry found he had
few memories of the following days
it was as though he had been through too
much to take in any more
the recollections he did have were very
painful the worst
perhaps was the meeting with the
diggeries that took place the following
morning
he suffered very little then she said
when harry had told her how cedric had
died
so again why couldn't harry see
thestrals at the end of goblet of fire
in an interview between jk rowling and
stephen fry
fry asks rolling harry saw his parents
die
so why hasn't he been able to see the
thestrals before
to which rowling responds at the end of
goblet of fire
we sent harry home more depressed than
he had ever been leaving hogwarts
now i knew that the thestrals were
coming and i can prove that
because they are in the book that i
produced for comic relief fantastic
beasts and where to find them
these unlucky black winged horses
however
if harry had seen them then and we
hadn't explained them then
i thought that would be rather a cheat
on the reader in that harry suddenly
sees these monsters
but we don't go anywhere with them so to
explain that to myself
i said that you had to have seen death
and allowed it to sink in a little bit
before slowly these creatures become
solid in front of you
so that's how i'm going to sneak past
that one this was not a great answer
but she does a better job of answering
it more comprehensively
in another interview when she was asked
why could harry see the thestrals in the
order of the phoenix
shouldn't he have been able to see them
much earlier because he saw his parents
quirrell and cedric die to which she
responded
i've been asked this a lot harry didn't
see his parents die
he was in his cot at the time he was
just over a year old
and as i say in philosopher's stone all
he saw was a flash of green light
he didn't see quirrell's death either
harry had passed out before quirrell
died
and was only told about it by dumbledore
in the last chapter
he did however witness the murder of
cedric
and it is this that makes him able to
see thestrals at last
why couldn't he see the thestrals on his
trip back to the train station
well i didn't want to start a new
mystery which would not be resolved for
a long time
at the very end of the fourth book i
decided
therefore that until harry is over the
first shock
and really feels what death means i.e
when he fully appreciates that cedric is
gone forever
and that he can never come back which
takes time whatever age you are
he would not be able to see the
thestrals after two months away from
school
during which he has dwelled endlessly on
his memories of the murder
and had nightmares about it the
thestrals have taken shape and form
and you can see them quite clearly
rowling later expands on this even
further on pottermore
further extrapolating upon the necessity
to fully understand
death and not just witness it being able
to see thestrals is a sign
that the beholder has witnessed death
and gained an emotional understanding
of what death means it is unsurprising
that it took a long time
for their significance to be properly
understood because the precise moment
when
such knowledge dawns varies greatly from
person to person
harry potter was unable to see thestrals
for years
after his mother was killed in front of
him because he was barely out of
babyhood when the murder happened
and he had been unable to comprehend his
own loss
even after the death of cedric diggory
weeks elapsed before the
full import of death's finality was born
upon him
only at this point did the thestrals
that pulled the carriages from hogsmeade
station to hogwarts castle
become visible to him on the other hand
luna lovegood
who lost her own mother when she was
young saw thestrals very soon afterwards
because she is intuitive spiritual and
unafraid of the afterlife
what this basically states is that there
is no rigid time frame that occurs for
one to begin to start seeing
thestrals it will vary heavily based on
the individual
harry hadn't yet processed cedric's
death by the time he was leaving
hogwarts
at the end of his fourth year as clearly
outlined in the text
when he looked back even a month later
harry found he had few memories of the
following days
it was as though he had been through too
much to take in anymore
but when he eventually returns to
hogwarts for his fifth year
he understood death and it had finally
sunk in
this meant that he was finally able to
see thestrals
in contrast luna saw thestrals much
quicker after her mother died
this is unconfirmed but i also like to
speculate that the death one witnesses
would have to be of significance to
whoever is witnessing it
it would have to be something that would
require emotional processing
someone that that person would have to
feel some amount of grief
for some people think that because harry
didn't actually see
cedric die and that he was only present
for his death
that this would somehow mean that he
hadn't witnessed death
an except from the text during this
scene reads as follows
a blast of green light blazed through
harry's eyelids
and he heard something heavy fall to the
ground beside him
the pain in his scar reached such a
pitch that he wretched
and then it diminished terrified of what
he was about to see
he opened his stinging eyes but this of
course
is a preposterous idea just because your
eyes are closed
it doesn't mean that you weren't there
that you weren't
present for the horrific act that
occurred witnessing death
is more than seeing the killing curse
penetrate cedric's body
it's about whether or not you are
present for the act witnessing death is
a lot more than just
what you are able to take in visually
additionally
this argument has no merit because then
harry shouldn't have been able to see
thestrals
until after the death of sirius which
happens
after the beginning of the order of the
phoenix
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content
please remember to like the video and
subscribe to the channel
as always leave your video suggestions
down below
until next time you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you